let's keep going through the grammar of
words this time we're going to focus on
the part of speech known as the pronoun
pronouns work a lot like nouns they
don't necessarily reference a specific
concept like a noun does but they can
stand in for now relate back to a noun
and they often share a lot of the same
properties just like with nouns we can
expect that pronouns can reference a
specific number so we might have a
distinction between singular and plural
or singular dual and plural this allows
some languages to distinguish between a
singular you and a group of you in the
plural pronouns also commonly show
person I am the first person you are the
second person he she or it is the third
person but notice that in English we
have a second set for the plural we are
the first person you all are the second
person and they are the third person
plural in English the third person
singular draws a distinction between
he/she and it but the third person
plural they doesn't make this
differentiation in Romanian on the other
hand gender is actually reflected in the
third person plural pronouns we have yay
for a group of males or males and
females mix gender and Yeley for a group
entirely composed of females or feminine
nouns the final property will talk about
when dealing with pronouns is case this
is easier in English because we actually
do distinguish case with our pronouns
unlike with our nouns think about the
subject or nominative case versus the
accusative or object case that I
introduced when discussing nouns I say I
when I'm the subject but me when I'm the
object compare I see you - you see me
both of these are first-person singular
pronouns in the first sentence it's in
the nominative or subject case i and ii
it's in the object or accusative case me
just as with nouns we can lay all these
properties out and we end up with a
declension of a pronoun you now have a
taste of the grammar of pronouns please
join me next time for an overview of
adjectives
you